how much you thought that the fact that
you sign is something you guys will use
the series
yeah come back
um someday we just went to a little
adjustment uh
different adjustments just throughout
the course of the game
um we did end up you know liking it
stayed with it for a while
uh maybe something we go to game two you
know rocks we gotta go back and look at
the film but I'm just thinking about it
right now uh something that we like you
know just to also have me you know
roaming and things like that so uh
good adjustment but like I said we'll go
back here and figure out a way we can do
better
in the project what did you notice about
the way Denver hit first so like what
was the key on the class and jokes and
everything and how did you guys find the
way that was done yeah I mean it took us
a half the end to the game and uh that
was pretty much the ball game right
there
we gotta understand that um you know we
got to start from from the tip-off you
know and uh
they punch this in the mouth to start
you know after they had more offensive
rebounds than we had total rebounds in
the first half and uh you know that led
to them getting Second Chance points
they also got on the fast break and
killed us in the fast break in the first
half you know and uh it was 10 percent
from the free-throw line so
you know I know the game is one in 48
minutes but they set the tone to 24
minutes and you know he's playing catch
up for the next 24.
[Applause]
or how do you feel like the team's like
to be affected by cutting the margin
down to three electricity tonight going
into the next game versus it's staying
out of reach
um I mean in postseason it doesn't
matter if you cut it to one or you're
down 20 if you lose you lose there are
1-0 and we have to come back with
desperation I'm going in the game too
they have to play better they have to
rebound better I thought we did a good
job when I turned the ball over that's
one thing we've been very conscious
about in the postseason but we've been
better in transition tonight we wasn't
that great in the first half we cleaned
up in the second half so we need to be
better at all fast is it again
where
it's a game always a game in between the
game and just reading the game and
making the proper reads you know um you
know they started to go to a you know a
three four five switching pick and rolls
where anytime I was involved with 80
they started to switch you know drunk on
to me and uh you know trying to keep
your body on body because 80 was doing a
great job of getting into that pocket
and and doing what he does best with his
floaters and you know things of that
nature so
um you know we have opportunities and we
know we can go to other things that that
also can work for us with you know
myself having a ball with Gars pick a
roll trying to get the good match up
seeing how they're gonna play if they're
gonna switch if they're gonna hard show
or whatever the case may be and we just
try to exploit that and allow AR to get
going in the fourth
you were very complimentary of jokic
before this game hey could you describe
how he played in in particular what did
you say to him when he made that crazy
shot right before that uh amazing
two-time MVP he very skilled
um you know obviously has his number
show made some tough shots you know we
just shot make a tough for him you know
switching on matchups and schemes on
them but
you know he he's been playing well
through the entire season and you know
especially in this playoffs so uh
you know you tip your hat to him
um
and then a shot here I mean he just
man I just looked at him and just smiled
I mean there's nothing else I could have
done
um
40 feet away from the basket you know
one dribble kind of
throws it up and it goes in so uh
you know definitely one of them nights
but uh
you know we encouraged about you know
second half of the game and
um things we can get better at and make
some adjustments once again too
on the court to start thinking you guys
to go small they're a pretty big team
and that at one point they had nine
offensive rebounds on their first 11
misses in the game how much of a factory
do you think that was
some of them was ever play some of them
were just out of um Out Of Reach um
you know we had a couple opportunities
to get early uh defensive rebound we
wasn't able to do that one of them was a
block out by me a joker coming down the
middle was one of his officer rebounds
um you know so
um you know I think someone was effort
some of them is about size but I think
for the most for the majority of some of
them ones in the first half we just
wasn't uh we wasn't just locked in we
wasn't in tune
um he had six offensive rebounds in the
first quarter he had six offensive
rebounds for the game so to just let you
know we started to get more and more in
tune what we need to do how we need to
block out how we need to hit bodies and
things of that nature
um you know and I think we got better as
the game went on
Austin and rui said they felt that there
was a lack of energy and especially lack
of effort in the first half do you agree
with that and how do you explain lack of
effort in game one of the western uh
we'll be better
um you know we know we didn't play up to
our capabilities in our first half and I
even thought in the third quarter when
they were making shots we were going
back and forth for making shots I
thought we was even we were still in
tune with it they were just making some
some some uh you know shots with hands
in their faces the bodies on bodies
um but
um you know we'll be better in game two
that's for sure
tonight and his performance but what
about a.d's offensive game was
impressive to you and do you feel like
he was able to keep you guys within that
Striking Distance in the first three
quarters there to make that fourth
quarter come back uh 80 was phenomenal
uh 40 and 10 change shots at The Rim
um you know
but he's been and he's been great all
post season so we're not worried about
that you know
um you know so we just have to do our
side we have to do our job as well you
know myself and I'm chipping in
everybody you know uh down down a ladder
from there so
um you know it's nothing that surprises
about 80s performance
um we got to do a great job of just
backing him up you know not only
offensive end to really pressure off of
him but also on the defensive end as
well when he's changing shots we have to
clean glass we have to help we have to
make our rotations clean that allows us
to do what we need to do offensively
appreciate it